hello and welcome to oops
object-oriented programming
my name is richard kirschner with the
simply learn team that's
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead in this we're
going to cover a basic
understanding of object-oriented
programming
and we'll be specifically working in the
python interface
or the python code oops the most con the
basic concept is not the accident you
just had or the mistake you just knocked
your coffee cup over off your desk but
it's actually stands for object oriented
programming and whether you're working
in python which we'll be doing today
or in any scripting language almost all
of them rely
on object oriented programming as their
basis programming paradigm that focuses
on objects so everything is an object
in the coding every instance in python
is an object and again this is true for
any of the main programming languages
you know if you're working in java or
scala
or any of these you're going to be
looking at object-oriented programming
it just makes a lot of sense and really
is the
one of the cornerstones of today's
programming and when we talk about
object
in programming an object has two
different things it has a
tribute has two different things
attributes which is data
describing the object and behavior
methods
on the attributes so the first one is
your actual data and the second
is what are you doing to that data and
if you're a car lover we're going to use
cars as an example this is kind of easy
to see how that might fit in
to the different objects and so we're
going to start with a bmw
for example that's an object and with
the bmw
you might have like the year of the
manufacturer maximum speed
those would be attributes of that car
and then you have the behavior
these are methods on the attributes for
example you might display the speed
or change the speed so even though you
have a maximum speed you might have
current speed also which changes
depending on what you want it to do step
on the accelerator go faster
step on the brakes go slower and the
primary terminology in programming is
usually class
and it's definitely true in python so
class is a collection of similar objects
and in this example we have car as our
class
so you might have trucks bicycles and
airplanes
but in cars we have some very specific
things cars have four wheels
that are on the ground maybe a spare
hanging down headlights steering wheel
things you would expect in a car doors
to get in so it's all inside
um but in here we actually have a number
in the collection we have our bmw
our ford our audi you can guess the guys
in the back like the bmw the best
i don't blame them and so we work with
classes or collection of items
today i'm going to use the user
interface pycharm it's one of the
very popular python editor i myself have
never used it so this is a new
experience for me
it's pleasantly fun to use and easy to
set up
you can go to jetbrains.com that's the
people behind it so www.jetbrains.com
pycharm slash and once you're on the pie
charm
if you go under downloads you'll have
two options let me just hit the download
now button i'll take you to the two
options
one is the professional which you would
pay for which allows
integration between teams and company
setup and has a bunch of extra cool
tools
you need for a business and then there's
a community version which is the lighter
weight one
for the purposes of this demo and most
the work you do
the community one's probably just fine
you can download it it's open source and
it's free
i don't know about you but i like open
source and free and a lot of my stuff
and i've already opened up a project
file but you can create a new project
file up here
put a note down in the youtube and they
can send you some of this code or go
visit simply learn they'll send you the
code itself if you need it
there's a lot of different like i said
functionality in here we're both
mostly going to be underneath just run
the demo in this case i'm doing oops
simply learn
so we'll just be running what i'm
working in here let's go ahead and start
with creating a class in python and you
simply just tell it it's a class
so the class means this is going to be
our python template
whatever we are working on i'll call
this car
and this is interesting because class
itself let me just highlight that
so when i put up class here that is a
python object and then i'm using that to
build car my class specifically on here
and let me go ahead and just change that
font i have it pretty large already
in my editor let's go back down here to
editor
font and i put it up all the way to 26 i
think we can get it by with 30 so you
can really see it
hopefully that's going to be big enough
on there and so once we have our class
we wanted to do something
and so in a class when you put the words
def that stands for definition
whatever that's called that is a
function
it's going to actually do something on
there and you'll see what i like about
this is nice
with pycharm it automatically
automatically puts self in there
why because self refers to whatever the
object is
now it doesn't refer to the template
class car
it refers to the instance of that and
i'll show you in a minute what that
exactly means
but in this case we're going to do
something simple we're just going to
have it print
and you see it automatically indents it
so python if you remember
or if you're new to python is based on
indentations
you have to indent so everything under
this indent is part of the def
everything under class it's indented as
part of the class
and so we're just going to look down at
our speedometer and we're going to print
155 miles per hour
maybe it's on the autobahn in europe i
don't know racetrack
not very often you go 155 miles an hour
in a car at least not in my experience
maybe in the future we have auto cars
that do hundreds of miles per hour and
shoot down the freeways
and let's go ahead and create an
instance of the class
and we'll simply do bmw equals car
and we'll put brackets on there and
let's also do
let's do a ford ford equals car
so if you remember car is like a
template it's still an object
so i have bmw equals car and i have ford
equals car
these are two separate instances so
they're copying or they're actually
putting a pointer to car
so everything under car is part of bmw
and the same thing with ford
and we can do something like this we can
go car
dot get speed let's put in the bmw there
or we could also do car dot get
speed forward given the choice i think
i'd go with the bmw
and there's another way you can do this
we can also do bmw
dot get because remember it points back
to the original template so all the
functionalities in the original template
and then we could also do forward dot
get
speed these are a little bit more
calming more than you'll see the top
part
but let's go ahead and run this and if
we go under run
we find out that alt shift f10 you can
use the hotkeys which i'll probably
start doing
and i just simply hit make sure i
highlight the one i'm working on and it
runs it down
here and so you can see right here we
have 155 miles per hour printed out by
the bmw 155 miles out printed by the
ford
uh car get speed and then i did it in a
different format
bmw dot get speed and forward get speed
the thing to notice is the term self
that is a python term which means that
when we create an
instance whatever comes in here is
what's being processed
and so if i call the class or the
template directly in this case i did car
get speed i have to include what that
self is in this case it's a bmw
or if i'm calling it from the instance
bmw
because it includes the car class it
knows that git speed and it knows
automatically
that this is self that's where the term
self comes in
so that's important to note in there in
python it's a one of the more
pythonic kind of solutions is that when
you see the term
self that refers to that instance that
you created
in this case the bmw instance and the
forward instance
when you're setting up a class there's a
lot of things you can do in here
there is a key term init what this means
is that when
i create the new instance whatever
happens
in here is going to be set this sets up
your information let me show you how
that works
and we're going to do is we're going to
pass year and speed in here
and this is really important is i need
to take self that's going to be the new
instance i created
i mean the k in this example will be our
bmw and our forward and
put a period here and then year equals
year that's the variable that was passed
and we'll do the same thing with speed
self.speed equals speed so when we
create this we now have
two different variables in here and if
you remember from our slide
an object has attributes data describing
the object
and a behavior methods on the object
and so in our class or our template
we're going to
knit it initialize it and hit it we're
going to initialize it with the year
and the speed on here but if we
initialize it here when we create the
instance we have to send that
information so that knows what the year
is and what the speed is for the bmw
and the forward and that means when we
create this instance let's go ahead and
do
2018 maybe this is the maximum speed
that shows up on the speedometer i don't
know but 2018
and we'll put it at 155 miles per hour
and then we'll take the ford
a little bit older runs a little slower
it's a 2016
and this will be the maximum speed we'll
do 140 miles per hour that's the fastest
it can go and then so now we we've set
up some data
on our object right here coming through
and so bmw
now has a year and a speed
and so does ford and when we get speed
let's go ahead and change this
and in fact i'm going to do let's just
get rid of this middle part because i
tend to do
the standard bmw.getspeed and we'll call
this
maximum speed maximum
speed is and then we'll just put down
self speed so that's our variable so
it's whatever the instance is
so self speed is going to refer to our
bmw or our ford
and if we go ahead and run this and that
was
go up here to run and alt shift f10 i'm
just going to do alt
shift f10 it's already set to the tab
i'm on
hit enter and we come down here and you
can see had an error there this is a
double underline for the init
the code that they sent me had just a
single and i forgot to double check that
uh so we have a double underline in it
it comes in gear and speed
the bmw has 2018 with a maximum speed of
155
and when we print that out bmw get speed
you'll see it right here the maximum
speed is 155
and then it does it for the fort maximum
speed is 140
and then we're done processing it so
we've stored some data in here we
started the year
we stored the speed and then we've had a
process on that data
and that is to go ahead and just print
it out print out the self.speed
and let's go ahead and briefly look at
encapsulation
def set speed self
speed so we're going to send it a new
speed value to set the speed
and from here we'll go ahead and do self
dot
speed equals speed and
we'll just work with the bmw on this one
let's take the
forward out of there for a moment and we
have our forward
get speed and we're going to set the
speed
and the new speed is going to be oh
let's make it 143.
just an odd number so it's easy to see
and then we'll go ahead and do
bmw dot get speed and when we go ahead
and run this
i'll do the alt shift f10
and run it as you can see here it comes
out and says
155 because that's what the speed was
when we first entered it
and then we went ahead and changed it
bmw dot set speed
and is now 143. so you can see here how
we can alter the information
in our template and if we remember we
had the forward
the forward is completely separate from
this so if we still have ford down here
equals car 2016 140.
if we still had that down here this 143
isn't going to affect the ford at all
because this ford instance is separate
from the bmw
so if i do forward dot get
speed and we do an alt shift f10
to run it there we go here's our forward
140 so it hasn't changed even though we
did we set the speed on the bmw to 143.
the first thing we want to look at is
inheritance and so inheritance is a
mechanism for a new class to use the
features of
another class and if you've ever done
like word processing you might use a
template
from that template you can have all
kinds of stuff you put into the template
and you can save it in different
instances depending on what you're doing
and then those particular instances you
saved could be used as a template for
your next thing you have a class
and from that class we can inherit
everything from there and then make
changes on it
and then we're going to go ahead and
cover let's do this
forward bmw just close that up take this
out of here for now
okay let's go ahead and do uh
inheritance
that's where we're going to take the
class car and we're going to bring all
these features from class car
into a new template or a new class
and let's start with a class sedan and
the sedan is going to inherit from
car so it's going to bring the car in
and now we have a sedan coming down
once we create the sedan this is now a
child class to car
coming down and under this class
i'll just go ahead and we'll just type
in
a def accelerate
course self and on here we're just going
to have it
print and oh let's have it do
let's have a do 150 that seems like very
high let's go 133 just because
i don't know why i like the 133 let's
change it to 137.
there we go and then let's do another
one here
we'll do this a class
suv and it also is going to inherit from
car and this too is a child class of car
so we'll just put a label there so we
can remember that
and we'll also give it an accelerate and
when we do an accelerate
keep the self and we'll print let's see
uh this year whatever production
is 180 i don't know why that seems
awfully high for an suv versus a sedan
let's do um uh 1 27. the suv
goes a little bit slower than the sedan
there we go so let's go and hit enter on
there and let's take a look at what we
got going here
i have my bmw i have my ford and let's
add a honda
and we're going to make it equal to the
sedan and just for fun let's add one
more thing
def open trunk
self a little bit uh print trunk
has been opened there we go let's take a
look and see we got going here i've
created my honda
if you remember up above we have our bmw
and i'll just do just the bmw
get speed and then i'm going to do the
honda
get speed and when we run this we can
see our bmw
is 155 and our maximum speed on our
honda is 150 because that's what we set
now remember this inherited it from cars
so this init
is now part of the sedan the open
trunk if we do this if i go the other
way around
let's say oh let's do this let's do the
honda open trunk
and then we'll do just to throw an
error here this is going to give us an
error it doesn't even auto type it for
me
so we'll do alt shift f10 and run it and
you can see down here
is that we had our bmw get speed
okay there's our 155 we had our
honda get speed we had our honda open
the trunk
and because our car when we go up here
to car does not have open trunk
the bmw does not have that definition so
it gives us an error
so we can't do that unless we add that
to the top as part of a car
it just turns out though that let me
just take the bmw out
for whatever reason this bmw doesn't
have a trunk i think they all have
trunks but that's okay for this example
we'll just leave it like that
so you can see right here we've
inherited and then we've gone ahead and
added
new features to our new class so this
child
class of sedan has come in here
now has both accelerate open trunk the
suv which we're going to look at in just
a second also has
open trunk so we've had a lot of
functionality when we have our original
car template so when whatever's set up
up here comes down here
and then we've added both accelerate let
me just do that right here or honda you
can accelerate the honda
and if we run that you can see the honda
has their acceleration come in and
prints out
in this case 137 down here that's why i
like to mark it with a weird
number like 137 so you can tell the
difference where we're going so we have
our accelerate so we've added features
into
our sedan encapsulation is a
important feature preventing data from
direct access
this is what we called encapsulation
we'll discuss that more later on but
what it means
in this particular case is that when you
create a class from another class
you can't alter the original template
the
child class can make all its own changes
to that class and do all kinds of things
but it can't make any direct changes to
the parent
let's go ahead and take a look at
encapsulation in the code itself
so we can have a better idea of what
we're talking about and so we have our
class car
and we have our definitions here's our
init this is from if you remember from
the last slide
we had our net maybe we had a couple
more functions to it or modules to it
and we have get speed and
set speed all of this under class car
is encapsulated what that means is that
if i create an instance of it in this
case i'm going to create a bmw
wouldn't that be nice if i can just whip
out a bmw make a bmw
when we create our instance bmw it does
not change the class car
this whatever we do to this instance
does not make changes
to our class and the same thing with the
ford the bmw
does a get speed it might do something
here in the definitions under the class
but the initial class if i create
another car let's say we take our bmw
we set the speed for 155 like we did
here and we create a ford
whatever i do with the 4 does not change
the class car
and if i create like we did before with
our inheritance
a subclass that's not going to change
the class car that's what they call
encapsulate
it bundles things together and it really
is central to
oops object oriented programming is
we're basically bundling things together
and then we keep them in a nice safe
bundle anything we do from that we
either
point to it and say hey let's use this
definition
or we make a copy of it so we kind of do
a combination of there and say okay
here's our new inheritance but you can
see right here this
is encapsulation and again that's like
central to oops this is how oops was
originally
discovered created and found it is when
they realized hey why don't we just
bundle things together instead of
rewriting the code over
and over and over and then polymorphism
we talked about encapsulation in classes
just recently like i said we'll go in
this and when we open up the code
polymorphism is we take the feature in
the code
and then we can alter that feature so we
can use the same function in multiple
ways
that's a lot of fun a lot of power in
that let's go ahead and take our
polymorphism and take a look at it
what's going on in the actual code when
writing our python code
so here we have our parent class car
and we switch colors here we have a
sedan
where we inherited the car and an suv
also an inheritance and we look at this
we have up here
our init let me just put so we have our
definition we're initializing it
the first class we've added in
accelerate so what that means is with
our acceleration that's not part of the
initial car class right now until we add
it in
so we have our definition accelerate
which print 150 miles per hour so all
sedans have
a print of 150 we need to accelerate all
other cars
don't have anything going on in them
right now and then with suv
we're going to define the accelerate
differently so we have the accelerate
down here with
self print 180. so we have two different
polymorphs going on here
we have accelera one polymorph going on
in this example
we've added accelerate to both of these
classes and so
it doesn't matter which one i accelerate
it's going to do something and so if we
create
in this case we're going to create an
object down here an instance of it
do this in pink here's our instances oop
that's a little light let's do something
a little darker than that one there we
go
so we have our instances and we're going
to create one object which is a sedan
a camry and one object which is an suv
scorpio
and then we can just go through the
objects we can actually just
loop through the objects one object at a
time and if we do print
object name and end we have our object
name
so it's going to print the name in this
case i'll print camry and i'll print
scorpio and then we have object
accelerate
and for the sedan since that's our camry
it's going to print the 150 and for the
suv is going to print 180 for the
scorpio and so by
doing this we polymorph the same
definition to do
two different things depending on what
our child class is
so we can polymorph all kinds of things
and we'll actually look at a couple more
objects in there when you go through the
full
code later on there's a couple more
examples in this but this is a
polymorphism coming down and you can see
how we
able to leverage the same name for the
definition to do different things
depending on what our object is
thank you for joining us today for oops
object oriented
programming by simply learn
www.simplylearn.com
come join us check out the classes feel
free to join our forums and
post questions you have on there or if
you have questions on this video you can
post them down below in the youtube
comment section and we will be
monitoring that again thank you for
joining us
happy learning and have a great day
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here